[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui deux états
antagonistes du maghreb à l'algérie et
le maroc historiquement complexe leur
relation viennent encore de se dégrader
faisant apparaître des risques
supplémentaires pour la région quel est
donc l'état des lieux actuel dans cette
confrontation opposant deux pays voisins
du nord de l'afrique le 24 août le
ministre algérien des affaires
étrangères annonce la suspension des
relations diplomatiques avec le maroc
une série d'accusations est également
avancé par la diplomatie algérienne
contre rabat notamment son soutien
présumé au terrorisme et au séparatisme
ainsi que l'espionnage la diplomatie
marocaine qualifie ces accusations d'
absurde et dit regretter la décision
algérienne très vite après la rupture
les appels au dialogue se multiplient de
la part de la communauté internationale
l'union européenne l'union africaine et
la ligue arabe proposent leur médiation
aux parties du conflit les médias
dévoile aussi la volonté de certains
pays de la région de s'imposer en tant
que médiateur à savoir la mauritanie
l'arabie saoudite l'egypte et le koweït
or la réconciliation reste une
perspective lointaine la rivalité entre
alger et rabat va crescendo les deux
pays cherchent à peser dans la crise
libyenne se livrent une lutte
d'influencé au sein de l'union africaine
et surtout continuent de s'affronter sur
le dossier épineux du sahara occidental
il ya aussi la coopération du maroc avec
israël qui irrite l'algérie farouche
défenseur de la cause palestinienne
[Musique]
avant de poursuivre voici une brève
présentation de ses deux frères ennemis
du maghreb c'est le blitz avec une
superficie d'un peu moins de 2 millions
400 mille kilomètres carrés dans 85% de
désert l'algérie est le pays le plus
vaste d'afrique son voisin de l'ouest le
maroc est cinq fois plus petit avec un
relief plus variés et une large façade
atlantique leurs populations sont de
taille comparable à la vente âge de
l'algérie avec environ 44 millions
d'habitants contre un peu moins de 37
millions au maroc au niveau économique
l'algérie se place au quatrième rang en
afrique avec un pib de plus de 145
milliards de dollars le maroc lui est
cinquième avec environ 113 milliards de
dollars la république de type
présidentiel l'algérie est dirigée par
abdelmadjid tebboune élus en 2019 le
maroc quant à lui est une monarchie
constitutionnelle gouverné par le roi
mohamed 6 qui a succédé à son père en
au plan extérieur les deux pays
s'efforce de diversifier leur
partenariat aussi bien avec l'europe et
les états unis qu'avec la russie ou
encore la chine au plan régional alger
et fortement impliqués dans le règlement
de la crise du sel et en particulier au
mali rabat cherchant trotta étendre son
influence en afrique subsaharienne et
nous récemment des liens avec l'état
hébreu
entre l'algérie et le maroc
rien ne va plus la rupture est décidée
par alger qui accuse son voisin de
soutenir le terrorisme et de l'espionné
la diplomatie marocaine rejette ces
accusations mais dit ne pas être
surprise par la décision algérienne car
ces derniers temps l'attention ne fait
que monter il s'agit dans un premier
temps de la question du sahara
occidental où l'algérie continue de
soutenir le front polisario mouvement
indépendantiste armé viennent ensuite se
greffer de nombreux autres dossiers
régionaux les deux pays entreprennent
par exemple des tentatives pour remédier
dans la crise libyenne nous se livre
encore à une lutte d'influencé au sein
de l'union africaine ceux qui héritent
surtout alger c'est la coopération
croissante entre rabat et tel aviv de
son côté l'algérie cherche à être
médiatrice dans le contentieux du
barrage du nil et exprime sa volonté
d'être garant de la paix au mali alors
qu'elle risque cette rivalité croissante
crétel pour la stabilité de la région
qu'est ce qui a déclenché la crise
actuelle quelles sont les perspectives
qui se dessinent pour les relations
algéro marocaines pour répondre à ces
questions nous rejoignons moussab
hamoudi chercheur en sciences politiques
à l'école des hautes études en sciences
sociales monsieur hamoudi bonjour
bonjour qu'est ce qui est la cause
principale de la rupture des relations
entre l'algérie et le maroc selon vous
alors déjà du côté marocain il ya
toujours le fond de la question du
sahara occidental et du front polisario
alors il y avait une série d' escalade
qui a commencé au niveau des
déclarations provocantes par le
ministère des affaires étrangères
marocain puis cette escalade s'est
transformé en un jeu une espèce de
ping-pong donc des déclarations marocain
suivie de déclarations algérienne
ensuite ces provocations se sont
transformés en hostilité à partir du 14
juillet c'est de 2021 c'est qu'on peut
retenir parce que lors d'une réunion des
pays non alignés le maroc a produit un
document officiel faisant valoir
le droit d amazir kabila
à l'autodétermination ce qui est quelque
chose de complètement inacceptable pour
l'algérie est curieuse parce que même le
royaume marocain opprime les images les
amazighs chez lui donc du côté algérien
la motivation est aussi
la gestion d'une crise politique interne
parce qu'on sait que le le régime
militaire algérien subit une vague de
protestation inédite c'est le irak une
vague de démocratisation populaire une
volonté en tout cas et donc l'objectif
premier de la junte militaire c'est de
sortir de cette crise alors comment elle
va faire elle va essayer de créer un
ennemi intérieur plus un ennemi
extérieur puis on l'est on est connecté
ce qu'elle va faire donc elle va cibler
des mouvements algérien minoritaire
voire éphémère rapidement je peux
l'expliquer pour bien me faire
comprendre
il ya le mouvement séparatiste qui est
le mac le mouvement pour l'autonomie de
la kabylie sans mouvement alain amazir
minoritaire mais autonomistes donc il
n'est pas national et le deuxième si le
mouvement
[Musique]
islamiste c'est un mouvement islamiste
et rachel donc mais c'est pas il n'a pas
une présence réelle c'est vraiment
éphémère c'est sur les lieux des
youtuber un peu lascars avec des fatwas
du dpi de golf dont cela elle valait
bien qu'il soit minoritaire elle va
essayer de les
concrétiser puis dire qu'ils sont
financés justement par le maroc donc le
masne le maroc intervient s'immisce dans
les affaires intérieures en agitant des
épouvantails ensuite le régime algérien
veut dire que tous passent surtout ce
package menace sa sécurité intérieure
donc ce soient les motivations du maroc
et de l'algérie quelles conséquences
cette rupture promet-elle pour les deux
pays aujourd'hui alors bien sûr il ya
les dommages sont là depuis longtemps en
vrai parce que le rappelons une histoire
a toujours été tumultueuses entre le
maroc et l'algérie en
1963 il ya eu même un conflit armé
concernant les frontières pourtant à la
sortie de l'indépendance de l'algérie
donc il ya eu une série de rupture
diplomatique il y a eu même des
histoires
sécuritaires la dernière et bien sûr les
écoutes vie à pegasus
c'est à dire il ya eu un seul moment de
salut c'était en
1987 lorsqu'il ya eu un rapprochement
mais que c'est une parenthèse dans
l'histoire des deux des relations entre
les deux pays et donc ça n'a pas duré
longtemps maintenant il reste un seul
dossier
c'est le dossier économique là où il ya
encore une coopération entre l'algérie
et le maroc sur le dossier du gazoduc
donc il ya un acheminement du gazoduc de
l'algérie vers l'espagne en passant par
le maroc est donc le maroc prélève sa
consommation pour sa consommation
interne en plus des droits de passage
sauf que ce contrat ne va pas être
conduit donc l'algérie a déjà préparé un
autre un autre le projet qui va
acheminer le gazoduc de l'algérie vers
l'espagne ils sont passés par le maroc
donc les conséquences se sont bien sûr
le la rupture définitive parce que le
dernier volet qui tenait encore c'était
ce volet là qui est purement économique
mais qui ne va pas trop conduit et donc
la rupture sera définitivement consommée
et du coup vous pensez que ça aura un
impact économique que ford pour le maroc
où pas mal aura donc moins de revenus
elle pourra pas compter sur les revenus
du dropt passe à l'état n'aura pas le
droit de la consommation ce qui va donc
augmenter les tarifications quelque part
et réduire la recette qui est quand même
importante c'est un impact fort
économiquement parlant c'est l'impact
fort mais déjà le maroc prépare le
terrain parce qu'il essaie un peu
d'avoir plus de présence en afrique
justement pour pallier à cette carence
et essayer de développer d'autres
relations en afrique justement pour se
passer du rôle algérien merci beaucoup
monsieur hamoudi nous allons poursuivre
notre analyse tout de suite mais nous
vous retrouverons à la fin de cette
émission pour plus de détails sur ce
thème merci encore la guerre froide
entre l'algérie et le maroc vient de
franchir une nouvelle étape le 24 août
le ministre algérien des affaires
étrangères
ramtane lamamra annonce la rupture des
relations diplomatiques avec le maroc
soit preuve
l'algérie a décidé de rompre ses
relations diplomatiques avec le maroc à
partir d'aujourd'hui est petit
une décision que l'algérie et justifie
par toute une liste d'accusations il
s'agit tout d'abord du soutien du maroc
à l'autodétermination du peuple kabyle
vit dans une région montagneuse du nord
de l'algérie la kabylie cette position
qui indigne les autorités algériennes
vient d'être annoncée en juillet par la
diplomatie marocaine à l'onu ensuite
vient la puis présumé du maroc à deux
groupes considérés comme terroristes par
alger le mouvement pour
l'autodétermination de la kabylie et le
rachad ces deux entités sont entre
autres accusé par le gouvernement
algérien d'être derrière les incendies
ayant ravagé le nord du pays ensuite
rabat est accusée d'espionnage sur des
responsables et des citoyens algériens à
en croire les autorités algériennes le
maroc se serait servi du logiciel
isralien pegasus à cette fin les
accusations aussitôt démentie par la
diplomatie marocaine qui réagit
fermement à la décision de l'algérie de
rompre les relations diplomatiques
le maroc regrette cette décision
complètement injustifiée mais attendue
au regard de la logique d'escaladé
constatée ces dernières semaines il
rejette catégoriquement les prétextes
fallacieux voire absurde qui la sous
tendent cette escalade découle d'une
rivalité croissante sur nombre de
dossiers régionaux dont le principal est
la question du sahara occidental
ancienne province espagnole située au
nord ouest de l'afrique elle est
revendiquée par le maroc comme faisant
partie intégrante de son territoire
l'algérie prône l'indépendance du sahara
occidental et soutient le front
polisario groupe indépendantiste armé
qui contrôle actuellement une partie sud
est ce du sahara occidental alors que le
maroc assure seule autorité sur la
majeure partie de la région disputée
après un cessez le feu de trente ans
entre le maroc et le front polisario des
affrontements éclatent de nouveau fin
2020 en réponse au blocage par les
indépendantistes d'une autoroute reliant
le maroc à la mauritanie rabat on voit
des troupes pourchasser les membres du
front polisario les échanges de tirs se
multiplient depuis dans cette zone
disputée l'algérie ne restent pas de
côté elle fournit une aide humanitaire
aux indépendantistes et appelle la
communauté internationale à la
solidarité avec le peuple sahraoui dans
cette escalade de tous sur un rôle
particulier a été joué par les médias
des deux pays après la rupture des
relations une véritable guerre
médiatique a éclaté entre les deux
voisins la presse algérienne désigne le
maroc comme le principal responsable de
la dégradation des relations elle parle
d'actes hostiles inamicaux malveillants
mais aussi d'une ligne politique
expansionniste du royaume qui menace
toute la région dans la presse marocaine
la rupture est présenté comme une
tentative de l'état voisin de détourner
l'attention de ses citoyens des échecs
internes et externes d'exporter ses
problèmes et de créer un ennemi virtuel
aujourd'hui pourtant l'algérie ne se
limite pas une offensive médiatique et
porte aussi un coup sévère au secteur
énergétique du maroc
le 26 août dernier le ministre algérien
de l'énergie affirme l'intention de son
pays de ne pas prolonger le contrat de
livraison de gaz naturel vers l'espagne
via le gazoduc maghreb europe passant
par le territoire marocain ce contrat
conclu en 2011 pour une durée de dix ans
permettait aux marocains de bénéficier
du droit de passage payer à en livraison
du gaz naturel algérien quant à
l'espagne l'algérie compile poursuivre
pleinement ses livraisons mais via un
autre gazoduc reliant directement
l'algérie et l'espagne par la mer medgaz
alors jusqu'où peut aller la rivalité
entre les deux pays car ces derniers
temps les deux états ne cesse de jouer
des muscles l'un face à l'autre rien que
cette année l'algérie mène deux vaste
exercice militaire près de la frontière
marocaine des chars des véhicules tout
terrain des hélicoptères des avions de
combat et des appareils ravitailleurs
quasi tous les types d'armement sont
déployés rabat répond par des manoeuvres
conjointes tenu cette année avec ses
partenaires internationaux notamment les
états unis et la france alors comment
cette escalade entre les deux voisins
peut-elle affecter la stabilité
régionale qui cherche à s'imposer en
tant que médiateur dans le règlement de
cette crise quelle est l'origine de
cette confrontation interminable entre
l'algérie et le maroc la réponse après
la pause
[Musique]
rivalités dans la région guerre
médiatique et énergétique la tension est
à son comble entre l'algérie et le maroc
cette énième crise entre les deux frères
du maghreb s'inscrit bien dans la
continuité de leurs relations
bilatérales qui n'ont jamais été simples
dès la période des indépendances les
relations entre l'algérie et le maroc
sont difficiles en raison des frontières
héritées de la décolonisation
le royaume chérifien qui a été
protectorat français pendant un peu
moins de 50 ans cherche à partir de 1956
à reconstituer un grand maroc historique
ils revendiquent le territoire de la
mauritanie une partie de l'algérie et le
sahara occidental région sous
protectorat espagnol depuis la fin du
19e siècle dès l'indépendance en 1962
l'algérie colonie française depuis 130
ans après plusieurs siècles de
domination ottomane le maroc conteste le
tracé des frontière avec son voisin
les incidents frontaliers se multiplient
et une guerre éclate en octobre 1963 au
nord-ouest du sahara algérien un
cessez-le-feu et déclaré quelques mois
plus tard sous la médiation de
l'organisation de l'unité africaine les
relations vont peu à peu s'apaiser et en
1972 le président algérien boumédiène
est le roi du maroc hassan 2 signent une
convention définissant la frontière
commune qui reste inchangé cependant les
rapports vont de nouveau se tendre au
moment de la décolonisation du sahara
occidental par l'espagne qui fait face à
la pression internationale
l'algérie soutient le front polisario
mouvement indépendantiste créée en 1973
et voit d'un mauvais oeil les
prétentions du maroc son rival régional
sur une région riche en ressources
naturelles en 1975 le tribunal
international de justice de l'onu rend
un avis reconnaissant le droit de la
population sahraoui à
l'autodétermination
de même que la cour internationale de
justice à la haye le roi hassan ii
organise alors une marche pacifique de
350 mille marocains qui entre dans le
territoire saharien en novembre 1975
quelques jours plus tard madrid
transfert l'administration de la région
au maroc et à la mauritanie qui en
revendiquent la partie sud ni le
polisario ni l'algérie ne sont consultés
en réaction l'algérie expulse de son
territoire des dizaines de milliers de
marocains et en 1976 les deux pays ont
rompu leurs relations diplomatiques
le polisario soutenu et armé par
l'algérie qui lui sert de base arrière
mène alors une guérilla contre le maroc
au plan international rabat se retrouve
isolé une résolution de l'onu
reconnaissant en 1979 le polisario comme
représentant du peuple sahraoui la
mauritanie renonce pas retraités au
sahara occidental le 5 août
reconnaissant le polisario comme seul
représentant légitime du peuple du
sahara occidental
elle se retire alors de la partie
qu'elle occupe et le maroc prend peu à
peu le contrôle de la plus grande partie
de la région dans les années 80 les
tensions entre l'algérie le maroc
s'apaisent à cette époque née l'idée de
la création d'une union du maghreb arabe
à l'image de la cee en europe en 1983
rabat et alger rétablissent la libre
circulation des personnes et des biens
est en 1988 les relations diplomatiques
sont reprises
l'humain est finalement créé en 1989
regroupant les cinq pays du maghreb
quant au sahara occidental cessez le feu
est signé en 1991 sous l'égide de l'onu
entre le polisario et le maroc qui
contrôle alors 80% du territoire en 1994
alors que l'algérie en pleine guerre
civile connaît une vague d'attaqués
islamistes une nouvelle crise éclate un
attentat perpétré par plusieurs
ressortissants français d'origine
algérienne et marocaine a lieu dans un
hôtel à marrakech tuant deux touristes
espagnols le maroc décide d'instaurer
des visas d'entrée aux algériens et
algérie poste en agissant de même et
fermé ses frontières terrestres avec le
royaume chérifien l'élection du
président algérien bouteflika en 1999 en
même temps que l'avènement du nouveau
roi mohamed6 au maroc
faut entrevoir une détente possible le
régime des visas entre les deux pays est
supprimée en 2005 mais les frontières
restent fermées au cours de la décennie
suivante les relations restent tendues
la question du sahara occidental restant
le principal contentieux l'organisation
du référendum prévu par l'accord de paix
de 91 est sans cesse reportée faute
d'accord entre le polisario et le maroc
sur la composition du corps électoral
dans le même temps les dépenses
militaires des deux pays augmente plus
de 100 milliards de dollars pour alger
entre 2010 et 2020 contre environ 44
milliards pour rabat l'année 2020 est
marquée par plusieurs succès
diplomatique marocain l'ouverture de
plusieurs consulats de pays africains
dans la partie du sahara occidental
contrôlé par rabat et la reconnaissance
en décembre par les états unis de la
souveraineté du maroc sur la région les
tensions sont ravivées fin 2020 lorsque
de nouvelles escarmouches ont lieu entre
le maroc et le front polisario
la querelle entre alger et rabat arrive
sur fond d' escalade régional surtout
l'épineux dossier du sahara occidental
ces derniers temps le maroc active sa
diplomatie pour obtenir l'ouverture de
consulats dans la région contestée
depuis fin 2010 9 une vingtaine de pays
ont déjà franchi le pas dont neuf pays
africains et trois états arabes y
compris des poids lourds comme les
émirats arabes unis ce qui conforte les
revendications marocaine sur le sahara
occidental et surtout en décembre 2020
quand cette souveraineté est reconnue
officiellement par les états unis ce qui
lui ouvre une nouvelle piste pour
s'imposer sur l'échiquier régional car
en échange du geste américain le même
jour rabat normaliser ses relations avec
tel-aviv au plus grand dam d'alger qui
traite israël d' entité sioniste et
soutient l'autorité palestinienne le
maroc devient donc le sixième pays arabe
à reconnaître israël un groupe de plus
en plus imposants d'ailleurs en plus
cette mesure permet au maroc de tester
son influence au sein de l'union
africaine qui l'a réintégré quatre ans
auparavant un test réussi grâce à l'aide
marocaine en juillet 2021 israël devient
membre observateur de l'union en échange
le maroc compte sur les investissements
israéliens et son appui diplômés tic y
compris face à alger et cet appui ne
tarde pas à arriver
nous partageons certaines inquiétudes au
sujet du rôle joué par l'algérie dans la
région son rapprochement avec l'iran et
la campagne qu'elle mène contre
l'admission d'israël en tant que membre
observateur de l'union africaine
la goutte d'eau qui fait déborder le
vase pour la patience algérienne dans sa
rupture avec rabat alger blâme aussi la
politique d'israël
le royaume du maroc a fait de son
territoire national une franchise
diplomatiques et une tête de pont pour
planifier organiser soutenir une série
d'actions hostiles et caractérisées
contre l'algérie les dernières en date
concerne les accusations insensé et les
menaces à peine voilées proférées par le
ministre israélien des affaires
étrangères
l'algérie tente en effet de contrer les
avancées diplomatiques du duo israël aux
marocains comme l'octroi du statut
d'observateur à l'union africaine à tel
aviv impact tout de suite rejetée par
alger début août la presse locale
rapporte que l'algérie et six autres
pays d'afrique envoie une note verbale à
l'union africaine il s'oppose à
l'adhésion d'israël en tant que membre
observateur et exige le réexamen de
cette décision la missive serait soutenu
par quatre pays arabes et la ligue arabe
pourtant aucun états mentionnés ne
confirme officiellement cette démarche
or le ton est donné plus tard dans le
mois d'août la communauté de
développement d'afrique australe
s'oppose ouvertement à l'adhésion
d'israël à l'union africaine résultats
l'union africaine doit céder et leur
examinera le statut d'israël à sa
prochaine réunion en octobre une petite
victoire pour l'algérie mais ce pour
longtemps c'est justement l'ambition du
nouveau ministre algérien des affaires
étrangères
ramtane lamamra a nommé en juillet
depuis alger s'active tous azimuts pour
bousculer les positions marocaines
exemple fin juillet la tunisie plonge
dans une crise politique alger et rabat
se bousculent pour manifester leur
soutien et envoient leur ministre à
tunis
le jour même en libye le maroc reste un
médiateur crucial depuis fin 2020 pour
lui disputer ce rôle l'algérie ranimant
septembre les consultations ou des états
du voisinage de la libye en dehors de la
confrontation directe alger s'impose
aussi dans d'autres dossiers régionaux
comme médiateur dans le contentieux du
barrage du nil et comme garant de la
paix au mali
l'algérie de par son histoire son poids
et ses responsabilités et prêtent plus
que jamais attiré les pays de la région
pour les aider à décoller à nouveau et
avec force vers la réalisation de cet
objectif escompté alger semble rattraper
ses positions rabat ne lâche pas non
plus les siennes dans la région mais
aussi dans le monde l'algérie renforce
ses liens avec la russie et la chine et
le maroc chouchoute les états unis et un
appel au dialogue se fait entendre
jusqu'à l'onu
je peux vous dire que le secrétaire
général encourage des deux pays voisins
a trouvé la voie à suivre pour réparer
leurs relations y compris en vue
d'assurer la paix et la sécurité dans la
région le divorce entre rabat et alger
est il définitif ou un compromis reste
il possible comment les deux pays
s'adapteront t-il à cette nouvelle
réalité et quels nouveaux enjeux
apporte-t-elle pour y voir plus clair
nous rejoignons de nouveaux moussab
hamoudi chercheur en sciences politiques
à l'école des hautes études en sciences
sociales monsieur hamoudi peut-on dire
que le maroc en quelque sorte battu
l'algérie diplomatiquement avec la
décision des états unis de reconnaître
la souveraineté de rabat sur le sahara
occidental
alors bien sûr le maroc a marqué des
points mais la question est un peu plus
complexe quand on y voir plus
précisément puisqu'il ya une autre
donnée importante qui ait le droit
international donc on sait qu'il y a une
mission onusienne pour organiser un
référendum au sahara occidental
c'est la mission la minuss trop la
minurso et il y a aussi un envoyé
spécial qui est d'ailleurs le russe
alexander yvan qu il y a aussi des
réalités anthropologiques de terrain qui
font que c'est très difficile donc le
fameux deal de trempe qui était la
normalisation via les accords d'abraham
en contrepartie de la reconnaissance de
la souveraineté du maroc sur le sahara
occidental elle n'impose pas à nestor
pas du moins un fait accompli les choses
sont un peu plus complexes et on va dire
que le maroc a marqué des points mais ça
ne lui permet pas de crier victoire en
termes géostratégiques quelles seraient
les répercussions de la rupture sur la
région toute entière oui très bonne
question c'est la fragilisation donc le
nord africain devient désormais de plus
en plus une zone à risque le lait c'est
le en fait plus précisément c'est les
voisins qui vont payer les pots cassés
parce que surtout surtout la libye et la
zone saine puisque finalement les
rapports entre l'algérie et le maroc on
avait dix n'ont jamais été au beau fixe
donc ce sont les voisins qui vont payer
on sait que la libye cherche un peu
elle essaie de se frayer un chemin vers
la stabilité mes a tant bien que mal le
chemin est très difficile et pour eux
essayer de réussir elle doit compter sur
ce qu'on appelle le voisinage donc les
pays du nord africains sauf que
maintenant pour faire face à la
concurrence des puissances
internationales
elle ne compte ni elle ne peut compter
ni sur le maroc mis sur l'algérie ni sur
la tunisie autant qu'un seul bloc c'est
à dire il n'y a pas de voisinage ce qui
fait que le que la libye sera livrée à
elle l'a elle-même à une seule et donc
elle sera sujet aux pressions
internationales sujet au rapport de
force entre les aimons et entre l'effort
ce moyen qui essaye d'être plus
expansionniste donc ici c'est le bien
sur la libye se trouve dans une mauvaise
posture entre le conflit est marocain et
libyen c'est la libé par dorian j'ai
rien c'est la libye qui payent le prix
reste aussi le sahel parce que le sahel
est une va s'affaiblir encore plus parce
que les données changent il ya un petit
recul français parce qu'elle l'échelle
on a vu il ya eu un retrait de sahel
mais en fait sous une autre forme il
reste une présence sous une autre forme
mais une présence turquie a un potentiel
présence russe donc la zone va être
encore une fois dans le flou elle paye
le prix parce que ce sont des régimes
fragilisé ce sont des régimes qui n'ont
pas d'assise
citoyenne m merci beaucoup monsieur
hamoudi je rappelle moussab hamoudi
chercheur en sciences politiques à
l'école des hautes études en sciences
sociales et est aujourd'hui avec nous
merci encore cette partie là n'est pas
encore terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial à
bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]